what should you guys um think of uh
opinion on
[Music]
taking pictures and posting them with
makeup on and taking pictures and
posting them
naturally like cat like do you want to
go to catfishing or you're talking about
like
just in general i use makeup i wear
eyeshadow and stuff like this see but
that's it do you is that for pictures or
is that for you that's because i think
it looks cool but like that's that's
interesting though like do you think
they do it differently then because
girls like me personally i'm never gonna
lie to you i've seen
like
girls that look completely different
without makeup on when i say completely
different i mean completely different
like you wouldn't recognize them
and i know those people in per in person
and
to see that it's like whoa like
for me as let's say a viewer a fan of
that person
to see you
with all your makeup and then that's not
you it's like did you sell me a dream
this whole time right now think what do
i do no do i unsubscribe do it like
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting i
barely wear makeup so
i think like
i think it's um
about like feeling beautiful so like if
someone doesn't look conventionally
attractive should they be allowed to
feel beautiful by wearing makeup i think
that's a good question like society's
saying like society says like women
should wear makeup regardless of what
you look like they're saying to people
that don't feel confident in themselves
they shouldn't be allowed to feel
beautiful so i think that's how like
that direction goes but on the other
side like
i do think makeup can be very deceptive
it can be well a lot of it is deceptive
yeah and the only reason why i ask that
is because most people like for instance
like you said before if a girl
takes a picture
her top off puts on instagram you're
going to get a bunch of attention but it
might be the attention that you're
looking for so it's like do how do you
go about that now do you
post natural pictures of you how you
really are every day or do you post
the way them pictures okay this is the
way i've thought about this okay this is
why this is why i don't wear a lot of
makeup like at all
one cause i'm lazy i can't keep up with
the trends it's just too much for me i
i'm trying to run a youtube show but
second second because if i date a guy
like i would never want him to like see
me without makeup and like like get a
guy that i'm not supposed to get almost
because i'm cakey yeah yeah because
i i don't like it when people
see you and they're like well what
happened you know i just would never
want that reaction
where i would rather not wear a lot and
then occasionally wear a lot and then
it's like oh like that's nice
rather than doing that every day
yeah yeah because i don't know i always
this is bad actually when i
when i was younger and i was on like
dating apps i'd always try to make
myself like look uglier because because
that way it'd be like a pleasant
surprise
i'm not saying this is a good strategy
probably not but it is
it's like
it'd be more genuine yeah yeah because i
was like i don't want to get a guy that
i'm not supposed to get you know like i
want the guy to be attracted to like to
my act like the way i look
and
yeah so i think
girls i don't except they would always
say take her to the beach you know like
go swimming
yeah yeah i think there's like a middle
ground i feel like there's like yeah i
agree with this like it's like putting
on a lot of makeup that will actually
change like the way you look yeah like
enhancing your own features
you don't you don't seem to wear a lot
like it seems light right yeah yeah if i
try to do foundation like number one i
probably wouldn't find a color that
matches my skin tone yeah yeah like
sometimes i just don't like the look of
foundation well and if i don't wear
makeup it forces myself to eat better
because if my skin's bad i'm more i'm
more motivated to like actually fix it
oh my god i did a tic tac today and i
showed my skin like six months ago it
was so red but then i was like then but
because i don't i can't cake stuff on
one i don't have the skill you know i'm
just not good at it but
yeah but two um i just i feel like it's
easier just to fix your skin than to
learn how to do makeup every day i think
that's a good point like i think like um
from the house side like if you wear
makeup you won't notice if you have like
you've not been sleeping if you wear
concealer every day you won't notice it
and your friends around won't notice so
i'm like oh like are you tired i feel
like it's good like to ask like are you
tired yeah and then you can like pay
attention to your health yeah yeah and
they sleep more like i should go to the
gym or yeah you know
like your body i think that's a good
thing